who is the riddler is he edward nigma or
edward nashton a wisecracking eagle
maniac or a psychopathic killer and how
does paul dano's version of the
character compare to the rest keep
watching for the answers to all these
riddles and more
even casual batman fans know the
riddler's real name edward nigma it's a
pretty obvious pun enigma sounds like
the word enigma referencing the
mysteries and puzzles that the riddler
loves to incorporate into his crimes
some viewers may be surprised in that he
has a slightly different alias in the
batman going instead by the less
familiar edward nashton that name wasn't
invented for the movie though in dc
comics it's the riddler's real name at
least it was for 25 years between 1986
and 2011 the period known in dc
continuity as new earth nashton was
riddler's canonical name though he did
change it to enigma as part of his
criminal ambitions after the events of
flashpoint however new earth gave way to
the new 52 in prime earth and the
riddler's real name reverted back to
edward nigma but with a y this time
live-action iterations of the character
in the past have used the surname migma
with both spellings including those
found in batman forever and the tv
series gotham while recognizable it's
fair to say that this name is kinda
campy too such an on the nose reference
to the character's obsessions doesn't
really fit with the tone or aesthetics
of the batman as a result matt reeves
movie has given a live-action iteration
of the character the name edward nashton
for the very first time
the most famous orphan in gotham city is
undoubtedly bruce wayne a child of
wealthy sociolites whose tragic deaths
were no secret to the population at
large in the batman's version of the
tale bruce became something of a recluse
following the deaths of his parents at
least that's the way the public saw it
in truth he was biting his time and
completing his training to emerge as the
dark knight still bruce rarely shows his
face in public the batman's riddler has
a bone to pick with bruce in particular
mostly because of the sins of his father
thomas wayne who purportedly associated
with the mob however in a notable change
from most other versions of the
character this riddler is jealous of
bruce the famous orphan the one who
didn't have to live in squalor in a
decrepit wayne orphanage that was the
harsh childhood the riddler endured
never receiving the proper care or
attention that displaced children
deserve instead he grew to resent the
city and the people that took from him
and others like him little did the
corrupt gotham leadership realize that
their greed would give birth to their
future demise
the riddler is typically portrayed as an
egomaniac with a morbid funny bone who
always fancies himself the smartest man
in the room being of superior intellect
he can't help but laugh and mock those
beneath him which is just about everyone
both the frank gorshan and jim carrey
versions of the character find humor in
their own hijinks they're outlandish and
cartoony villains who crack jokes make
puns and belittle their opposition with
sarcastic wit
caffeine will kill you
the batman on the other hand presents a
riddler absolutely devoid of any such
humor displaying a kind of subtle rage
instead like many batman villains he's a
dark reflection of the dark knight they
both exact vengeance on the wicked they
both wear masks and they both warn
criminals to fear them their intellects
are comparable too but this riddler
isn't nearly as fixated on his own
superiority where previous incarnations
were mischievous and colorful this
riddler is dark and terrifying a
psychopathic stalker who horrifically
bludgeons his victims in the shadows of
their own homes he still deals in
puzzles short but paul dano's
performance creates a striking portrait
of an unhinged man unleashing his own
brand of righteous fury upon gotham city
the riddler of the batman would fit
comfortably in a slasher movie and
unlike his predecessors he has precious
little to laugh about
the riddler's plots are pretty much
always foiled by batman sure he's killed
many people over the years and has
enacted plenty of destructive schemes
but it's rare for any villain to
actually succeed in wreaking real
devastation on gothel in the third act
of the batman however the riddler
actually succeeds in his grand plan
unleashing a flood to cleanse the city
of its filth batman is still something
of an amateur at this point and this is
very much a movie in which batman makes
mistakes including failing to deduce the
riddler's final plan in time the film's
true resolution is batman's
acknowledgement that he must be more for
the people of gotham than a vigilante
pounding baddies into the pavement every
night instead he must be a symbol of
hope when batman is seen providing aid
and relief to victims of the flooding on
the news in arkham the riddler is
angered the last thing he wanted to do
was bring a sense of unity to the people
of gotham and bolster a new champion for
the people still ridler did at least win
the battle even if he won't win the war
in the colorful pages of dc comics the
riddler is often as pompous as they come
he would never happily share the
spotlight as he simply craves it too
much the riddler is destined to be a
one-man show and he'll live out the rest
of his days trying to one-up and defeat
batman if it's the last thing he does
despite the riddler's comic book
predilection for hoarding all the
notoriety paul dano's take on the
character is noticeably different while
the riddler obviously prides himself on
his capability to toy with law
enforcement he ultimately has one
objective in mind justice in the face of
corruption as such the riddler finds a
sense of kinship with the dark knight
seemingly a crusader for justice just
like him later in the film the batman
reveals that the riddler's messages for
the batman weren't a taunting game they
were an invitation to join forces for
most of the film the riddler believes
the batman is actually on his side
simply because their goals seem to align
they'll remember me now
they'll remember both of us
it's only when the riddler is locked up
that he realizes the batman was never
actually aiding his cause
the riddler's aggression is typically
levied against the weak and powerful
alike his primary objective is to
elevate himself as a notoriously brainy
criminal and to exert dominion overall
especially batman that's simply the
nature of the game for an extreme
narcissist like the riddler and the
previous live-action versions of the
character all fit the mold of a
power-hungry megalomaniac bent on
destroying batman it's extremely rare
then to see the riddler portrayed as an
anti-hero of sorts there are a couple of
exceptions the 2013 video game batman
arkham origins includes an early career
edward nigma who has hidden extortion
data all throughout the city in an
attempt to highlight gotham's deep rock
also like in the batman the version of
the character from batman earth 1 is
also a serial killer waging war on the
corrupt these are the only instances in
recent memory in which the riddler
flirts with anti-hero status however
until the batman which clearly counted
earth 1 among its inspirations the
riddler's war is seemingly a righteous
one in his own eyes he wants nothing
more than to see the evil and greedy
elite of gotham suffer and pay for their
injustices it's a riddler we haven't
seen before in live action and it adds a
whole other layer to this deeply
tortured character
the riddler is probably kidding himself
when he says he's not mentally unstable
like the rest of batman's rivals after
all a certain degree of obsession must
be involved for him to commit to a
never-ending conflict with a man dressed
like a bat but killing isn't a highlight
of the riddler's career it's merely a
means to an end typically the
puzzle-spinning crook finds joy in
outwitting others especially a prominent
and intelligent figure like the batman
daniel's riddler certainly has a few
screws loose but that's the result of a
lifetime of neglect living as an outcast
in a cruel city like gotham in the
batman the riddler seems to be the exact
opposite of his comic book counterpart
the riddles are a means to an end not
the end themselves this riddler isn't
seeking to outsmart anyone he derives
joy not from a feeling of superiority
but from the satisfaction of knowing
he's about to end someone who's done the
city dirty he also savors his kills the
introductory scene in which the riddler
stalks the mayor in his own home is
chilling but he doesn't kill his target
immediately even though he has the
chance the mayor's family is out
trick-or-treating and no one else is
around yet the riddler remains in the
shadows apparently enjoying the moment
as much as possible it's a long long way
from this guy
adios amigos
see you in court
the batman paints a bleak and quite
original picture of edward nashton's
history nashton's troubles began growing
up in wayne manor repurposed to be an
orphanage and seeing both the building
and the lives of his fellow orphans fall
into disrepair when the funding dried up
thanks to gotham's greed the orphans
were forced to live in squalor
fortunately edward developed his
signature coping mechanism early on even
as a child he fixated on solving puzzles
the hobby helped him to bide his time
and turn his focus away from his tragic
life nashton's pension for enigmas
served him later in life when he became
a forensic accountant a career choice
that led directly to him taking up arms
against the corrupt the skills he gained
enabled him to piece together the theft
of thomas wayne's renewal fund which was
ripe for the picking after wayne's
untimely death that was the moment
nashton realized he owed his dark past
to gotham's shady elite and vowed to
bring them down
every villain needs henchmen there's no
way men like the riddler could contend
with batman physically on their own as
the dark knight is far too great of a
physical force to be reckoned with loyal
guns are essential to making a splash in
gotham city and most of the time
villains already have them at hand when
the story begins
we're usually left to infer that the
henchmen are either well paid terrified
or both and while that's probably a
reasonable assumption the batman does
things a little differently the batman
finds the riddler living in the modern
age of social media attracting hundreds
of followers throughout gotham via
online ramblings about his crusade
thanks for all the comments and a
special thanks to everyone for the tips
on detonators
essentially the batman's riddler
radicalizes and recruits followers for
his war against gotham's elite those
like-minded individuals who have also
been victims of corruption show up in
mass to help assassinate the newly
elected mayor bella real and terrorize
the people of the city it's an
impressively modern twist on villainy in
an age of widespread online interaction
the riddler often has a distinct design
that's instantly recognizable to most
comic book fans outfitted with
sunglasses or a black or green domino
mask he always comes off as something of
a fashionista donning a green bowler hat
and a green suit adorned in question
marks there have been several variations
on that theme over the years including
jim carrey's eccentric showstopper in
1995's batman forever but the riddler's
appearance has typically been as
distinct as it is familiar in contrast
the batman presents a villain who seeks
to conceal his identity for obvious
reasons wearing little more than a mask
and practical clothing this new attire
makes complete sense in the world of the
batman where getting revenge means
getting your clothes dirty along with
your hands daniel's riddler has neither
time nor use for flashy spectacle his
costume design is simple yet iconic
conveying everything the people of
gotham need to know about the man
wreaking havoc on their city he's
enigmatic he's practical and he means
business check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]